Peter J bety is a professor of economics
and philosophy at George Mason
University and the director of the fa
haek program for advanced study in
philosophy politics and economics at the
marcada center recently elected as the
president of the Mont pin Society he
earned his ba at Grove City College and
his Ma and PhD in economics from George
Mason University a former professor at
New York University Dr Bey was a
national fellow at the Hoover
Institution for war Revolution and peace
at Stanford University from 1992 to 1993
and the fa hyek fellow at the London
School of economics in 2004 and 2006 he
is the author of numerous books
including why Paris sta failed the
politics and economics of socialist
transformation calculation and
coordination essays on socialism and
transition political economy and living
economics yesterday today and tomorrow
please join me in welcoming Peter J
[Music]
bety thank you so much for that
introduction it's a thrill for me to be
here at
Hillsdale um Shayla mentioned uh my book
why parist failed when I was uh still in
my 20s I gave my first talk at Hillsdale
College and my discussant on my talk was
Alexander stros who's a was a professor
of history and political science here at
Hillsdale for many years and I was
talking about gorbachov and perista and
when he got up here he says we don't
need perista we need Desta you know like
that and I always remember that you know
so uh the system but I I've had a
tremendous uh uh respect and
relationship with Hillsdale over the
years uh one of the takeaways uh from
from my talk here has been that Austrian
economics um is a growth industry um I'm
going to be leaving here and I will be
going back to Washington DC where I am
responsible for the southern economic
Association meetings this year Southern
economic Association is the second
largest meeting of professional
economists in the United States outside
of the American economic Association I'm
the president elect of that group and
our Austrian Group which is involved
with that as a society for development
of austri Economics will have its annual
dinner on Sunday night and we have a a
ballroom set up for 200 guests I think
that it's somewhere between 150 and 200
um is what we're have already signed up
and that's the largest ever when we
first started the society for
development of Austrian economics 20
years ago there was a table for
10 okay and uh one of the things that I
as a message to the students that are
out here uh Hillsdale and Grove City
College when I decided to go to college
were the only places in the United
States that you could learn about the
ideas of mises and Hayek and that's no
longer the case but that's because of
what Hillsdale has done and you look at
the graduates from Hillsdale College and
what they have G gone on to do um as
well as from Grove City and multiply and
expand these ideas so that these ideas
are actually very much a part of the
economic conversation um throughout the
economics profession worldwide and and
um so I've chaired um over 40
dissertations now and many of those
students are teaching in PHD programs
and they're generating their own
students and just as importantly if not
more importantly I got a ton of students
teaching actually in undergraduate
schools and generating the students that
come then to the graduate schools
including here at Hillsdale and uh so
I'm thrilled when I come here because I
get to see for example professor Charles
steel who was a student of mine at NYU
uh way back when when when I was a young
pup and he was a young pup studying and
uh I it's amazing to see what he's gone
on to do I just had one of his former
students was Adam Smith fellow in a
program that we run at mercades Brian
Leonard who's a graduate from Hillsdale
went and got his PhD at University of
California at Santa Barbara and now uh
Brian has just accepted a job at as a
tenure track professor at Arizona State
University and so these ideas are
spreading out all over the place but
besides Charles you have Ivon pongrass
and Chris Martin um and uh so it's just
an amazing sort of uh experience here um
and of course Michael Clark um so I
think I have more former students
teaching at Hillsdale than any place
else so I love Hillsdale keep hiring
more of them I got a bunch of them I got
CVS in the back um but so that's uh
that's the sort of academic ease kind of
idea um but I'm here to talk to you
about the Contemporary relevance uh
mises and Hayek and the Austrian School
here's the easiest way to sort of get at
some of the talks from earlier in its
relationship to mine Mis is in my
opinion is the greatest Economist that
ever lived and hyek is his greatest
student all right and then what we're
trying to do is the hybrid approach of
Misa and Hayek as it develops in a as a
scientific research program in economics
and then what is its contemporary
relevance for the world that we live in
uh today let's see if I can negotiate
this the right way there we go so the
main points that I want to get across is
first just a quick overview of the
contributions of Misa and Hayek and the
Austrian School and how they must be
understood as firmly within the mainline
tradition of economic scholarship
tracing back from Adam Smith to Vernon
Smith um so for the students in here if
anyone tries to tell you that you're not
a mainstream Economist you should resist
that all right cuz in the hist history
of Economics the 200 to 300 year history
of Economics the positions that you're
being taught by your professors that's
what it meant to think like an
economist it's only since World War II
that economists thought anything
differently what happened was a series
of events happened that dragged
economics back into the Dark Ages away
from what we had learned from Adam Smith
all the way up to John Stewart
Mill and dragged Us in instead as KES
himself put it to the Rogues gallery of
economics meaning all the people who
didn't actually believe in
economics and that's what you continue
to be taught in various different
languages whether or not that language
is English whether or not it is in
German or whether or not it's in French
or whether or not it's in mathematics
what matters is a subsi of content of
what's being taught and if people don't
tell you about the gains from
trade all right and about that the
competition is a discovery and the
invisible hand then they're not teaching
you
economics all right and so you guys
should go out in the world with
tremendous confidence not ever feel that
you're an outlier because you actually
sit in the seats of Adam Smith so what
are those main tenants of the Austrian
School um I'll try to go over those and
how they've evolved I won't be able to
delve into them uh and then the Austrian
School represents this sort of IAL
challenge to the postor War II consensus
in economics and I'm going to sort of
suggest that that consensus is grounded
in an alliance between statism and
scientism what we call progressivism and
why that's um uh should must be resisted
and then finally identify and uh
identification and application of these
ideas to the serious problems caused by
the
consensus so that consensus took place
it generated all kinds of problems in
our economy which we're still dealing
with and we're not seriously discussing
them and what we need to do is be
trained to have serious conversations
and I'm going to focus only on three and
those are the fiscal
Gap or to put it uh more colloquial uh
irresponsible fiscal policy okay and
then exit strategy for the fed or
unsound money and structural
inequality and what I'm going to focus
on is the gumming up of our labor
markets and of the expansion of rent
seeking now let me Define the term rent
seeking very quickly because one of the
times I spoke at Hillsdale College I
talked about rent seeking and then one
of the guests came up to me afterwards
and said they love my talk it was great
they didn't realize that it was all the
landlord's fault uh rent seeking has
nothing to do with the landlords uh rent
seeking is basically government
privileges to special interest groups
what Ronald Reagan and uh and Milton
fredman identified as the Iron Triangle
right that what you have in the tyranny
of the status quo is you have your
permanent bureaucracies you have your
politicians and then you have your
interest groups and they align and they
prevent any kind of change and one of
the factoids that you should
all uh sort of take into account and
think about is that in um when I went to
graduate school at George Mason Unity
University in
1984 um Washington DC was not exactly a
Mecca of wealth and
culture in this last financial crisis
eight out of the uh uh eight out of 10
of the richest counties in America were
outside of Washington
DC and that's not because any wealth was
being created that was because wealth
was being transferred from very
hardworking people like you and the
neighbors that you grew that you live
with to in fact my
neighbors who know how to take money
from some and turn it into themselves
not that I'm endorsing her but I and
Rand had a wonderful discussion in Atlas
Shrug in which the whole problem was
that the Moochers and the looters align
to rip off the producers and over the
last 20 years of the United States we've
seen this take place and that's the
taking culture that exists and how are
we going to get ourselves out of that
taking culture is going to be a main
topic all right so let's get
started little free advertisement it's
PowerPoint got advertised this my book
living
economics um economics for yesterday
today and tomorrow Martin is here at uh
independent Institute published this
book um in cooperation with the
university Francisco
Marine um and um and so the book is
available in Romanian and Spanish and
it's coming out in Chinese and a variety
of things and the basic idea of this
book if you can look at the cover that's
why I have it up here is that economics
uh science is forever changing just like
the leaves on the tree are you know gr
branching out and developing and
evolving but an evolving and healthy
tree has Deep
Roots right you can't knock that o that
oak tree over right and the reason why
those deep roots are and in economics
those deep roots are in the Scottish and
Light of of David Y and Adam Smith and
all the various different branches that
come out of that and so it's really the
case that as Lord Acton once put it it's
not the popular movement but the
traveling of the minds of men who sit in
the seat of Adam Smith that is really
serious and worthy of our attention and
what is
it that we do if we sit in the seat of
Adam
Smith and here's what we do we derive
the Invisible Hand theorem
spontaneous order from the rational
Choice
postulate individuals try to do the best
that they can given their situation via
institutional
analysis what are those
institutions property prices and profit
and loss what Bob Murphy earlier was
talking about in the economic
calculation argument that Mis has
identified those key ideas keep in mind
that understanding the role of property
goes all the way back to Yume Yume
argued for example that you couldn't
have Society unless you had three
institutions which was property
stability of
possession right contract meaning
transference by consent and contract
again keeping of promises so without
property contract and consent Society is
going to break down into what the Hobs
and jungle life will be nasty brutish
and short
and so why is it that an economics could
exist that doesn't take into account
those three sort of fundamental
institutions property prices and profit
and
loss so again how do we derive the
Invisible Hand theorem from the rational
Choice postulate via institutional
analysis that is the defining
characteristic of an economist in the
main line of economics and you can read
about it in the Scottish Enlightenment
you can read of it in the French liberal
School of John Baptista SE and Frederick
bastiat and you could read it in the
British utilitarians and John Stewart
Mill and you can read it in the early
Austrian economists in Carl manger and
bavi and then in the more mature
Austrian School in mes and Hayek and
then in the Contemporary Austrian School
it's this focus on
institutions that is a key part of how
you drive the Invisible Hand
theorem now my wife makes fun of me all
the time because she says Pete it's a
power point not a power
paragraph so I understand that there are
propositions that are sitting there that
you can't read but my slides are
available and could easily be
distributed so you can have them and um
this is a book that I edited uh from a
few years ago called the handbook of
contemporary Austrian economics and that
book um what I did was I focus on
spelling out the 10
propositions that are associated with
this tradition of economic
scholarship what I'm going
to tell you is not the 10 propositions
I'm going to tell you the implications
of the 10 propositions but first let me
just say that the second proposition on
this board says that we study that uh
the way we pursue economics is that you
study the market order as fundamentally
about exchange and the institutions
within which exchange takes
place so that goes back to what I just
said before and then the sixth
proposition is going to be that private
property and the means of production is
necessary condition for rational
economic
calculation the seventh is going to be
about the competitive market as a
process of entrepreneurial discovery
which you learned from Professor Kerner
the other day who was Professor Steel's
disertation adviser and my senior
colleague when I was at NY
you um and the leading figure in the
modern Austrian School the eighth one
which relates to Bob Murphy's talk is
that money is non-neutral easy way to
understand
this money is one half of all
exchanges if you screw around with money
you're going to screw around with the
exchanges in the
economy right money buys goods and goods
buy money Goods never buy Goods in a
modern economy
so money is a link between all exchanges
so if you screw up that money unit
you're going to screw up those exchange
relationships between those
goods and then the ninth proposition has
to do with capital and again capital is
made up of heterogeneous and
multi-specific heterogeneous Goods that
have multi-specific uses now why does
this
matter all right let's make it very
straightforward many of you have had
kids or
grandkids your kids or grandkids might
be fascinated by
dinosaurs now you're going to try to
play dinosaurs with your kids you can do
it by getting a Lego set that has
Jurassic
Park and you have to put together the
dinosaurs or what you could do is simply
try to do it with
Plato now Plato is
homogeneous and and can be used for all
different kinds of things and if you
make an error with Playdoh right I say
look Matt here's you know look at this
this is this is now I'm going to have
this like brosaurus he says no dad that
looks like a duck so what do I do I just
squeeze the neck a little bit and make
it longer now all of a sudden my duck
becomes a brosaurus
but how many have you ever tried to like
AB lib with
Legos right it's these intricate pieces
that you have to fit together and
usually you have the sheet all laid out
and you got to follow and you're looking
around like where's that little like
orange piece where's this little piece
like that well that's what prices and
interest rates do for us in the modern
economy because our modern economy is a
lot more like Legos than it is like
Playdoh and if we model our economic
process as if it's like Plato we're
going to underestimate the cost of
making errors in
coordination because we're going to
think it's Costless to correct the
errors but actually when you make an
error with Legos what do you have to do
you have to disassemble and then to use
a term that that Bob used in his talk
you have to
recalculate that's what's constantly
going on in capitalism when it's
revealed that errors have been made
entrepreneurs have to engage in
recalculation and
reallocation that's the way markets sort
of function so what are the implications
of this one you cannot model economic
agents as if they're benevolent and
omniscient two you cannot view economics
the economists as giving advice to
benevolent and omniscient social
planners so professor wolam in here is a
public
Economist all right and he understands
issues about Public Finance and and
whatnot what you can't do Buchanan James
Buchanan who is the Nobel Prize winner
in that field what his argument was
against the sort of more standard
Harvard MIT approach was that you cannot
offer advice as if you're giving it to a
benevolent Des spot and what he meant by
that is you can't assume a stable social
welfare function that's going to pick
some kind of optimal tax scheme that's
not the way in which public economics is
done instead public economics is part of
an exchange it's an exchange within the
political process and we have to study
that made up of very imperfect people
not benevolent and omniscient agents so
that's implication three we live in a
world of imper an imperfect World
populated by imperfect beings in which
we are trying to find institutions that
allow us to live better together than we
ever could
apart what you should think of to
yourself whenever you're talking about
issues of the rules of the game is a
neighborhood in which we are are
constantly bumping into each other and
bargaining with each
other that's the Economic Institutions
within which we
interact it's a very imperfect world
with imperfect beings that try to come
up with institutional
Solutions so that we can live better
together than we ever could apart or as
L vanon mises put it we could realize
the social the the gains from social
cooperation under division of
labor so Bob was talking about why Misa
called the book Human Action that's true
for the reasons B Bob gave a great
presentation on that but here's one of
the other things misa's thought about
maybe naming the book social
cooperation because if you read the book
that's the core idea of the book it's
how is it that social cooperation
emerges from all these individual
active uh you know uh participants under
a certain set of
Institutions um he also used to refer to
his work as sociology not praxiology but
what happened was the word sociology had
been become corrupted so if you read his
book socialism the subtitle is an
economic and sociological analysis um
praxiology the term comes around in the
30s um fourth implication institutional
problems demand institutional
Solutions all right so at least we got
some of this down other references this
goes back to my growth industry point in
1994 I edited a book called The Elgar
companion tost economics I understand
Professor Clark uses it in class here uh
which is fantastic I I thank you
Professor Clark but in 2015 I just
published a new handbook which is by
Oxford University
press Oxford came to us to do that I
edit a book series for Cambridge
University press when Larry white
published his book free banking in
Britain with c Cambridge it was the
first time in Austria was publishing a
book in that kind of idea I now edit a
series all right the world is
changing Young
Folks right Austrian economics is a
growth industry don't ever let anyone
try to tell you that you can't be an
Austrian Economist and be extremely
successful in this profession it's just
not true it's a it's a fallacious uh
position now it doesn't mean that you're
going to be happy meaning that people
might not like you and you got to so you
have to say like who
cares all right so here's the problem
now let me step back for a second for
the people
here in a broader sense what Hillsdale
College represents and Grove City and
these other schools represent is we
represent an older tradition of what it
meant to be an American and what I mean
by that is it's grounded in what teville
recognized to be in America which is
that the American Society was in fact a
self-governing Democratic Society that
put emphasis on
citizens citizens capable of living a
free life this is why in fact tovil also
talked about the problem of atrophying
those capabilities of being a
self-governing citizen that could happen
when in fact the government plays too
big a role in your
life and that's pretty much what toille
had recognized it's this Jeffersonian
system that we had that existed in
America and then what happened is at the
end of the 19th century
wilsonian ideas started to creep in and
become Encon in the system it started by
the way with the management after the
Civil War of dealing with the Civil War
veterans this is the first sort of
interest group that gets formed and we
start changing the dra drastic uh idea
of the United States by the way it's
also important that the Civil War you
got to remember is that prior to the
Civil War it was these United States
after the Civil War it became the United
States there's a difference in that
language that's important we got
permanent bureaucracies rather than
citizens that were uh going in and out
and you transformed American public
American public
administration this took place under
woodro Wilson and you substituted
professional trained bureaucrats for
were citizen
Governors and they also started to argue
that the Constitutional constraints on
the power of government were
annoying and that was a huge thing they
did not want constitutions to
pinch because remember what the original
idea
was President a alluded to
it Madison says right men if men were
Angels would be no need for government
if Government to be run by Angels
there'd be no need for restraints
precisely because we have to man is
going to rule over other men we must
Empower and then constrain this is what
the Constitution was designed to do
which meant that Constitutions are
supposed to pinch because what we're
supposed to do is have a system where
bad men can do least
harm not a system where the bright the
brilliant and the wise can do what's
necessary all right we are going to
trade that off to make sure that bad men
can do least
harm well if public administration
throws that off and says no we're going
to have trained experts and in fact
trained experts that are immune from
democratic checks and balances which was
the rise of Independent Regulatory
Agencies the most important of which is
the
Fed right so the FED for the young
people here fed didn't always
exist right it came about 1913 it didn't
exist before that all right and so right
the income
tax right when did that come about right
this all comes around in in in during
World War I okay Federal Trade
Commission right Federal Communications
Commission these are all the independent
regulatory agencies and these rise of
these independent all the way up to the
EPA The Independent Regulatory Agencies
rely on trained experts immune from
democracy to provide the right public
policy if economics is an input into
public
administration if you transform public
administration you're going to transform
what we want out of
economists and that's why you had the
change in the consensus it wasn't that
the that the previous classical to
neoclassical consensus was
overturned it was that the demand of
what economists should be doing was
overturned and economists rather than
being students of civilization which is
what they referred to themselves
beforehand now all of a sudden we're
expected to be saviors of the
civilization the best biographies on
economics of an economics person by far
are the ones on John mayard KES in the
second volume by skeli of the three
volume set is called Economist as
Savior you have to understand something
about canes canes was such a powerful
intellect he controlled the artwork for
his own
books which is a very rare thing for an
author To Have and when he published the
end of f Fair the artwork is a
lighthouse that has a person at the top
which has beams of Brilliance coming out
of it that's
Cain's all right and that's how Cain saw
himself and that's in fact how everyone
around Cain saw him and so this becomes
we no longer are students of society we
are now saviors of societ Society
there's no such thing as a council of
sociological
advisers there's a council of economic
advisors right and so now how did Hayek
and mises react to this well hyek has a
great line he says the economist is
called upon to offer his advice to those
in power more often than any other
social scientists to only have his
advice discounted as soon as it's
uttered and why would that and Jesus has
a great line where he says you can't
understand the history of Economics
unless you understand that the economist
is a gadfly to those in positions of
power because those in positions of
power want to promise things and want
Utopia to happen remember Bob's story
about the politician coming and saying
oh yeah you can just build the Gazebo
and not worry about right so many of you
read Thomas Soul what's Thomas Soul's
line first rule of Economics there's
scarcity first rule of politics there is
no scarcity all right so economists and
politicians have always been at
loggerheads with one another until what
until this transformation and then
economists were expected to in fact be
servants to the
state all right well this has effects
methodologically we tried to come up
with new uh justifications for our
scientific method uh Bob talked about
this idea of the aping of the Natural
Sciences mises to try to communicate
this to people had a funny little quip
he would say if you throw a rock into
water it sinks if you throw a stick into
water it floats if you throw a man into
water he must decide to sink a
swim all right now that's you know uh
Fritz mockup mis's his student he had a
another kind of quip about it he just
wrote a paper called what if matter
could
talk and he's explaining like what the
physicist is in front of the class
giving a lecture and then all of a
sudden like the molecules say no you got
that wrong that's not why I did that
right and like mocup says the physics
Professor is all confused right so
economists have to deal with this idea
of homo agents this this active
purposive being and you know this this
is the this uh kind of agent defies the
idea that we only have uh closed end
systems with single exit options which
is what equilibrium models Force us to
do that we have smooth and continuous
and twice differentiable functions so we
can understand a local Optimum and a
global Optimum we can build those models
but those models don't necessarily
capture what the economist is trying to
do
now I understand my audience a little
bit and I understand the lateness of the
evening so normally at this time I would
go into a big philosophical discussion
about the issue of soundness versus
validity and logical models and blah
blah blah not going to do that but if
you want to email me kids go ahead I'll
talk to you till you're blue in the face
about it um but what happened was
economics moved in a mathematical
Direction which ensured only validity
but not soundness ask your logic
professors to explain that to you and
then the reason why that was okay was
because we thought we had developed
sophisticated statistical tools that
would sort from array of logically valid
models those which were empirically
significant and that whole Enterprise is
BS
and it was it's BS in physics as uh
durkheim and Quin uh I mean d Dam and
Quin established early part of the 20th
century and yet economists have never
caught on but that's one of the reasons
why we have very poor replication rates
all kinds of other things like that so
analytically so methodologically we
moved in the direction of formalism and
positivism meth mathem analytically we
moved in a model of mathematical models
of equilibrium and statistical tests of
uh significance
and ideologically this methodological
analytical tools were used to justify
government as a corrective to social
ills so you got microeconomic regulation
and macroeconomic demand
management
okay why do I have a guy juggling balls
on a thing so I want all of you as a
research assignment teaching assignment
to read the fifth book of The Wealth of
Nations it's Adam Smith this chance to
finally give advice to what is the
implications of the smithian system to
the
Statesman and when he comes to sum it
all up he says governments ancient as
well as
modern when confronted with their Folly
have always sought to engage in juggling
tricks in which you run deficits
accumulate public debt and then debase
the currency to pay the public debt back
back it's a juggling trick deficits debt
and debasement when it gets out of hand
like happened in Rome you destroy an
economy so because the threat is so huge
Smith councils stop the juggling let's
figure out ways that don't allow public
officials to be able to engage in
juggling and that was the General wisdom
in economics from the time of Adam Smith
to John mayard
KES that we should limit
juggling and in fact it became two key
ideas not radical libertarian ideas just
two key major ideas of what it meant to
think like an economist which was
optimal fiscal policy which is that in a
time of Crisis you might run a deficit
but as soon as you're out of the crisis
you pay it back and that's just called
optimal fiscal policy so imagine a trend
line like this and now you have like
oscillations against the trend so you
have a boom and a bust during the boom
phase right what you would do is you
would have surpluses during the bus
phase you'd run deficits over the life
of the business cycle what would you get
a balanced
budget and Smith even used the metaphor
of what's good for you and your
household is good for the
nation that was optimal fiscal policy on
the monetary policy side we get badget
rule okay we have a central bank that
Central bank is in operation To Be A
lender of Last Resorts but here's the
problem in times of Crisis the Central
Bank should be a lender of Last Resorts
only to those banks that are
solvent and never to those banks that
are
insolvent if you're an insolvent Bank
sorry you're out of the market
goodbye but well how did badget rule
happen in practice after this both
solvent and insolvent Banks always get
bailed out that's called the too big to
fail kind of idea okay so we don't want
people
juggling John mayard KES came along and
he said no no no no come on we need to
just be Master jugglers we're going to
train economists to be able to ride on a
tight
rope while bicycling along and juggling
all these different
balls and they can do that heck we built
a bathtub and you have monetary policy
the hot water
right fiscal policy the cold water and
we have an equilibrium level that's
called the Phillips machine and look we
can do it like just a little bit this
Goldilocks right right you get the right
flow if there's leakages in the system
which is savings we got to clog that
up this is Keynesian economics in a
nutshell Keynesian economics is income
expenditure
economics it's to the students in here
it's the 45 degree line
all right with the aggregate demand
curve you have an unemployment
equilibrium and you have a full
employment equilibrium that you're
supposed to get to and that the way you
get to it is by government
expenditure that's the essence of the
Keynesian model an unemployment
equilibrium that can only be broken by
government as a corrective as a DE
mchina to move us from here to
there this is the juggling but what if
we get it wrong
if we underestimate what the multiplier
will bring us we actually get
unemployment if we do what if we
overestimate what do we get we get an
inflationary
spiral that's just right in the model
okay
so Bob was talking about a question was
raised to Bob about World War II here's
the deal in all the best
estimates of world war II's the
multiplier the multiplier was less than
one okay government expenditures didn't
help us out that's Christina romer's
work all right Christina RoR when she
was working for the Obama Administration
all of a sudden claimed that that tarp
would somehow have like a multiplier of
10 which is why that tarp program didn't
get us where we were supposed to go it's
because it's unrealistic in the history
of Economics but it was a political
number that they needed to have
okay so we have these juggling
tricks and this leads to the mess that
we're
in this is fa hyek from his Nobel Prize
address I want you to just do a little
thought experiment close your eyes for a
second imagine that it's
1974 and Fa hyek has just been given a
Nobel prize in
economics we're suffering from
stagflation the world is dominated by
Keynesian economics and now they just uh
gave an award to the leading opponent of
canes at the time can's wrote fredman is
the leading opponent of can's after
can's wrote so fredman is an opponent of
keynesianism but the direct person who
battled with canes was in fact
Hayek the economics profession had moved
a lot since the 1930s and here is hyek
in 1970s we have indeed at the moment
little cause for Pride they had just
established a Nobel Prize in
1968 as a profession we have made a mess
of things it seems to me that this
failure of The Economist to guide policy
more successfully is closely connected
with their propensity to imitate as
closely as possible the procedures of
the brilliantly successful physical
sciences an attempt which in our field
may lead to outright error it is an a
approach which has come to be come to be
described as scientistic attitude that
attitude which as I defined it some 30
years years ago is decidedly
unscientific in the true sense of the
word since it involves a mechanical and
uncritical application of habits of
thought to Fields different from those
with which they have been formed I want
today to begin by explaining how some of
the gravest errors of recent Economic
Policy are a direct consequence of this
scientistic
error so what are these errors first at
a metal level right the alliance of
statism and scientism
what did that produce It produced two
things government is viewed as a
corrective and therefore an active
player in the economic game no longer
just a
referee so if you were watching the
World Series and you were rooting for
Cleveland all right what happened when
Chapman came out to pitch is what they
should have done is grab you know not
Chapman Miller right they should have
grabbed the back of Rizzo and just held
it the referee the UMP behind the plate
as Rizo I was getting ready to hit the
UMP grabs the bat so what that's okay
I'm a keesy and
ump right so I can be an active player
in this game I can put my thumb on the
scale what did Adam Smith think that the
state should be doing he should be what
a night
Watchman right how did Thomas Carlile
The Great critic of Economics describes
Smithy and economics it's Anarchy with a
constable that was the criticism right
because the conable supposed to be
watching not be interfering all right so
you're supposed to be able to be a a
referee not an active player so that's
one two economics is transformed into an
engineering science economics is
supposed to be about engineering it's
social physics it's no longer a moral
philosophy or a branch of moral
philosophy so what's the difference
between then and
now well not much in terms of the
attitude among a lot of economists
though there is a growing sense of
opposition and the problem is is that
what Hayek identified as the problems
were simply literally papered
over and that's what I'm going to try to
demonstrate to you right now um a good
friend of mises and hyek was a man named
Albert
Han and Albert Han wrote a book in the
1940s called the economics of Illusion
and his argument is that keynesianism
was going to do was engage in the
economics of
Illusion which is it's going to like be
smoking mirrors to make you think that
the economy is operating at full
employment but instead it's kind of what
Bob was talking about on false accounts
and so sooner or later those accounts
are going to have to come
du and that's what we're facing
today
so the first thing is the fiscal Gap
this Associates with the work of lence K
he a professor at Boston University he's
an expert in the field of what's called
intergenerational accounting what
intergenerational accounting does is it
tries to see what are the obligations
that government owes you and what's the
ability of the
population at the time when those
obligations are due to pay for them
discounted back to today today's dollars
so we can compare apples and apples and
this is different from the official
debt so the official debt is around
$19.5
trillion okay the fiscal Gap is around
200 to $25
trillion we're not going to be bankrupt
we're already
bankrupt all right understand this this
point now the picture on the your left
my right is is uh Uncle
Sam can's had a great line uh so you
heard me say something good uh about
can's um but kan's at a great line he
says you cannot make a fat man skinny by
tightening his
belt this has to do with the scale and
scope of
government all right so it's not we
always talk about the scale of
government but the real issue is the
scope what's happened in post World War
II is the scope of government has
continually grown greater and greater in
the United States rather than just the
scale scale goes with the scope so if
you actually want to reduce the burden
of the government in your lives you have
to demonstrate that you can not starve
the state of resources that's the old
sort of conservative challenge all right
it's instead starve the state of
responsibility State's not necessary for
Education State's not necessary for
Health and Welfare right you can have
private alternatives to that and you
have to start thinking about where it is
that we can actually cut down on the
scope of government and then the size of
government will go with
that okay let me just point out what
klov puts on the table for us if we want
to survive this fiscal Gap and return to
Optimal fiscal
policy what K Lov estimates is that for
you guys who are in college today that
your marginal tax rate during your most
productive years given the current
marginal tax rate of around 28% will
have to increase by
60% so that you're right so that
your marginal tax rate when you're
trying to build a family will be about
88% okay welcome to the
1970s and by the way we still still
would have to slash government programs
by 40% across the
board folks we have to get serious about
dealing with this
issue so what's one way we deal with it
one way we deal with it is
repudiation that has all kinds of
implications another way we deal with it
is
monetization I'm going to get to that in
a second that has huge that's Adam
Smith's juggling
trick the third one
is a tremendous expansion of a
technological innovation meaning growth
exponential growth how many here have
ever heard of of
kurile and the
singularity this is a little too weird
right but you know the singularity idea
if you look at what he says he says once
we hit the singularity our growth rates
are going to go like this right we'll
have right if we had that then we would
get out of this problem you can grow
your way out of this
problem but that's not that's kind of
difficult if if we're going to have
restrictions on Innovation which I'll
come to in a
second all right so what's our next
serious
problem this is the balance sheet of the
FED on the on the the the right the my
left your
right okay on the the the little funny
graph Bob Murphy made reference to
operation twist which is the purchasing
of government securities at 85 billion a
month
understand that that's been going on 85
billion there's an earlier policy which
is called qe1 to QE n that was going
on why haven't we seen inflation how
about the fact that the government
actually pays Banks to hold on to the
reserves they're paying interest on the
reserves so the banks in fact have been
holding on to
cash let that go let's see what happens
all right uh as I said before we
violated badget rule and we gave because
of the the the idea of too big to
fail and if we go back before the
financial crisis we have to recognize
that there's such a thing as the green
span put which is that every because we
can't easily sort out between good
deflations and bad deflations I don't
have my cell phone on me but I love to
always put up my cell phone when I
bought my very first computer in 1984
guys I bought a Radio Shack TRS you can
look it up in the
Smithsonian okay it had floppy discs you
guys don't even know what floppy discs
are they're called floppy discs
precisely because they were floppy and
you had to put one in as the operating
system to then be able to operate the
other one
$2500 okay
$2500 to type on Okay my
smartphone the computing power is that
is off the charts compared to that I got
it for $200
$300 that's good deflation because it's
productivity
gains all right but precisely because we
can't sort out good deflation from Bad
deflations every time that the there
seems to be a deflationary tick the
government wants to stimulate the
economy and that's actually what
Greenspan
did so Greenspan was not an advocate of
the market in practice he was in fact a
extremely aggressive fed chairman and he
created the financial bubble that led to
the financial crisis in
2009 combined with a bunch of other
policies that we engaged in and the
question is whether or not Bernan has
left us in a situation where we do not
have a viable exit strategy from this
behavior that we engage I do I have a
pointer I don't know there that blue
line going way up okay getting technical
now all right
I'm running out of time so let me just
get through here
inequality folks do not read
picky okay read
zingalis all right now why do I say you
can read picky everyone should read
whoever they're reading but he's
actually not have a good argument it's
like silly it's like even like if you if
you look at Darren asoglu response to py
he explains why it is py doesn't
understand a lot of basic economics but
G Galis does and he wrote a book a year
before pik's book it's called The
People's capitalism and he argues about
the difficulty in the United States
because when he came to the United
States from Italy he came because the
United States was a merit a meritocracy
and Italy was in fact based on
connections not on contracts and he and
so he knew if he stayed in Italy he
couldn't get very far but he could come
to the United States and if he worked
really hard he'd be able to climb up and
become what he's become a famous
economist okay and his concern is might
not be able to do that
today because why because we put
restrictions on everything we've made it
more difficult and and Casey Mulligan
professor at the at University of
Chicago has a fantastic book called the
redistribution recession all of you
should get a hold of this
book and what he argues is that over the
last 25 years we have in fact raised the
cost of hiring people and lowered the
cost of being
unemployed so why are you surprised that
the labor market is all gummed
up right labor markets are the way in
which we get ahead in the world when
work disappears what happens you go and
look at what happened in Baltimore for
example and where the riots were and
then look at the number of discouraged
workers in that area of that of that
City okay this goes this is what this
number is capturing here these are
people that are not discour discouraged
workers not in the labor
force okay so yes our unemployment rates
officially measured right now seem to be
low why because people stop looking and
so therefore they no longer get counted
as
unemployed in the official statistics
because they're discouraged workers so
what you should look at is when the
government releases it statistics look
at Labor particip ipation rates not just
the unemployment
rate what else is going on we have
minimum wage legislation which will
continue to gum up our labor markets
overtime
restrictions right overtime restrictions
which are now getting passed which will
gum up our labor markets these are all
the kinds of things and then here's
another big
one we've become a more rent seeking
Society 25 years ago Microsoft did not
have a lobbying Wing now it has one of
the largest lobbying groups in all of
Washington
DC what
happened should have had a
V8 we have become a rent seeking society
and as a result that means that we Grant
privileges to the few and restrictions
on the
many these all have to be
addressed shouldn't be a surprise to
anyone who's a Hillsdale student because
this is the legacy of Lord canes when
you unleash the deficits debt and
debasement you have political and
economic consequences I've been telling
people since 2009 if you want to
understand what's going on in our system
you need to read two books by two Nobel
Prize
winners the best Nobel Prize winners
actually in my opinion Hayek tiger
botale which is about the inflationary
legacies of Lord KES and Jim Buchanan
deficit democracy and deficit which is
about the political consequences of
fiscal
imbalance so what can we
do well institutional problems demand
institutional
fixes students in here put on your
thinking
caps you have to think about the various
different the fiscal problem is a
consequence of having a fiscal commment
imagine a dinner Club
in which you all go to eat dinner
together and you agree beforehand that
you're going to split the
bill now decide are you going to get an
extra drink how about an extra canoli at
the end of dinner right a canoli cost $4
but you don't have to pay the full $4
because you're splitting it with
everyone else so it only cost you $2 so
on the margin you'll have another
canoli imagine that for the entire
economy one giant dinner
right or as my teacher Hans sennholz at
Grove City College you know who I love
dearly what he used to say is you know
imagine a society we in a giant Circle
and it's all have our hands in the
pockets of our neighbors right that's
kind of the fiscal Commons that's been
Unleashed in this okay and so how are we
going to make sure that you do that
you're going to have to change the
incentive arrangements so for those of
you who are here and we get ready to
think about the new Administration or
whatever always remember policies have
to be incentive compatible if it
requires an omniscient or a benevolent
actor it's not a good
policy so it has to be incentive
compatible and then you have to have
incentive compatible strategies to
implement it so you need fiscal
responsibility we need sound
money and we need permissionless
Innovation we need to get the government
out of our entrepreneurial process we
need to unleash the human capital of you
young people to be able to go and start
a business and start and come up with
new ideas to solve all of these issues
and we're going to need to do that and
we're going to need to do it
quick let me end on a positive note
however Adam Smith
noted that the power of our
self-interest was enough to overcome a
100 impertinent obstructions which human
Folly puts in its
way so we can think about this as a
horse race that our society is
confronted with we have the Smith horse
which is The Good Old Reliable horse of
trade domestic and international
trade we have the sharian horse which is
the strong horse of
innovation new ideas creative
destruction and then we have the old hag
stupidity which is Washington
DC if you allow Washington DC and
stupidity to get ahead of shumer and
Smith don't be surprised if your economy
goes into the
toilet but if we can unleash trade and
Technology we can put up with a lot of
Ruin in the nation as Adam Smith
pointed okay and so we can tomorrow can
be better than today if I imagine a
total Factor productivity curve and then
a trend line off of that so a boom and a
bust all right now you have trade in
technology what that does is it doesn't
move you along that factor productivity
curve it moves the curve
up and what you need to do is make sure
it goes up enough so that tomorrow's
trough is still higher than today's
Peak if that's the case tomorrow will be
better than
today it won't be as good as we'd like
but we'll still have a better life for
you than what I had and your kids will
have a better life than you had
that's what's under
threat because where is the discussions
coming from constraints on permission
Innovation constraints on your labor
markets all right this difficulty of the
budget imagine how difficult it will be
if you face 88% marginal tax rates and
what kind of incentive you'll face for
working this is where the problem comes
in so what we need to do is we need to
recognize Mis his main point about the
reserve fund and capital accumulation we
can't continually engage in policies
which lead to Capital consumption rather
than capital accumulation and we need to
unleash the greatest resource that
Humanity has which is the human
imagination and unleash it to be able to
come up with the new and better ideas so
that tomorrow will be far better than
today thank you very
much
[Music]
thank you very much Dr Becky we now have
time for one or two questions please
raise your hand and the microphone will
be brought to
you can you give me my other
glasses this is one of the technologies
that haven't happened yet
yep I'm list Dr bety I'd like to hear
your thoughts on bitcoin it seems to be
a very good um example of permissionless
innovation and sound money however many
austrians have critiqued it for uh not
meeting manger regression theorem that
is it cannot be traced back to some form
of a useful commodity thank you yeah so
Professor white was here the other day
he's like along with Larry with George
San those are like the leading experts
in monetary economics uh from an
Austrian perspective um and Larry's
talked quite a bit about Bitcoin and
some of the other uh ideas I think it's
a fantastic Innovation and the market
will determine whether or not it can
stay you know the problem with the share
economy I have in my notes to talk about
the share economy and the modern
technology economy is take a look at uh
the way in which governments are
constantly trying to respond in each of
those areas so Uber gets going what do
they try to do shut the Uber economy
down right uh Airbnb gets going right
they want to shut down the Airbnb
they're going to try to go after Bitcoin
because the issues with Bitcoin were try
to evade government oversight right now
keep in mind that Peter teal when he
originally founded uh PayPal he was the
original like Bitcoin right in some
sense he was trying to come up with an
alternative currency he was a student at
at Stanford very radical libertarian and
he wanted to come up with a currency
which was outside of the view of the
government but he ended up by being a
payment system it's improved our lives
and stuff but it's not an alternative
currency so I don't know what's going to
happen I do know that all the
predictions of the demise of Bitcoin
have been overstated as of yet um and so
I'm just sort of looking and watching I
don't have a real strong dog in that
hunt um you know it's it's you know it's
pretty cool will Luther one of our
former graduates from George Mason look
him up he has the survey articles on
bitcoin that you can put in the whole
perspective and give you a better
grounding I would not rely on internet
Austrian
ISM it's a note to all of you there's a
thing called the library it existed
before Google all right uh go to a
library pick a book up that's actually
like been done not some guy on the
internet in his basement with YouTube
channel telling you what's cool and uh
you know sort of look into this but will
Luther has these social science research
Network papers on bitcoin he has the
main surveys so great great question
though you have one more question
oh thank you l in your talk you
mentioned we should look at two books I
thought you said Hayek tiger by the tail
and I did not get the second book uh the
second book is democracy and deficit by
James
Buchanan and uh and Liberty Fund uh had
published the collected works of Jim
Buchanan and so that book was reprinted
and available in a very inexpensive way
through Liberty Fund uh to read it's a
it's a fantastic book about the legacy
of of Lord K's in
politics thank you thank you very
[Applause]
much